le très haut débit pour tous d'ici 2020
c'est l'objectif que s'est donné le
conseil départemental des yvelines
vendredi 20 mai à versailles pierre
bédier président du conseil
départemental et karl olive ont présenté
le syndicat mixte ouvert yvelines
numériques une structure publique créée
par le département qui permettra de
déployer le réseau très haut débit pour
le grand public comme l'expliquent son
vice-président alors plusieurs solutions
d'abord la possibilité d'être fibre est
très rapidement ça c'est la première la
deuxième pour des aides pour des zones
un tout petit peu plus reculée où je
dirais la les kilomètres de voirie
affaires et km de fibres à pouvoir
accomplir sont trop importantes
il ya une montée en débit qui est
proposée sur les 232 commune yvelinoise
seulement 104 sont gérés par les
opérateurs privés 158 communes sont donc
concernés par ce nouveau syndicat des
zones essentiellement rural cent mille
foyers attendent encore d'être équipé du
très haut débit à 7 au service public de
se déployer mais ce service public
aujourd'hui il a un coot le coot il est
assuré par les contribuables
donc c'est cet équilibre entre le
consommateur et le contribuable que
notre collectivité et cei
de mettre en oeuvre de la façon la plus
pertinente possible
le syndicat yvelines numériques envisage
d'investir 110 millions d'euros pour
mener à bien cette opération financée en
majorité par le département 9
intercommunalités adhèrent déjà au
dispositif les territoires de versailles
grand parc et saint-quentin-en-yvelines
n'en font pas encore partie